did te Donald Trump yeah I [__] that boy
we Ain got like talk too much about that
[__] I gota ask I gota ask that's
fire you
got how that
happen why is the sound on this I know
it's popular podcast why is the sound so
bad it sounds like they're in a [__]
iron
lung so why is this so e hey guys get
these thing
hey Nori get these things get the waffle
things that you put
up it sounds like they're in a [__]
Hangar it said I'd change my life
tonight if Donal TR reduce my sentence
sir can hear the air conditioner only
reduce his sent he pardon you that is
pretty cool he pardon him for what what
it call that black do Rob [__] two
million dimes good [__] that's hard hard
hey you guys what are you
saying dude was Kodak Black's mom a
creaky
door never been done before he Gemini
again here Gemini like his birthday
three days after my [__] and I Bo like
he be vibing out here too right so so
Trump right now even though he probably
don't need it if he needed a million
dollars would you give him a million
dollar of course
[__] I didn't even know um on
that PS were how you want people
grab what he say that there having know
people and people can grab
it wow his mom was a crooky door dad was
a dying
Deer
uh dude I love I love rappers man I love
how
they my favorite is beef though when
they have
beef I don't understand well I'm a
rapper [__]
it I guess wait hold
on Soulja Boy oh when does Soulja Boy
not have be remember when Soulja Boy
tried to make a video game console you
know and then it didn't work because of
course rappers are crazy bro they're
crazy for a rapper to just be like yo
you know I'm going to make video games
is
nuts do you know what I mean there's
nobody other people doing
that imagine like [__] Tim salmon is
just like dude [__]
PS5 do you know what I'm saying imagine
Jerry Seinfeld is like I hate playing WI
I'm going to make the Seinfeld
[Laughter]
3000 you put the cartridge in
P welcome to the Sun instead of Sega it
just goes
[Music]
Pampa what is the deal Pampa
bro he made a video game console what
was it called I don't even know what was
the Soulja Boy video game console called
Soulja Boy Video Game Boy video
game
padel what's his name has beef with
um Soulja Boy has beef with um uh uh Jay
Cole or
whatever big
sea soldja boy had some hits though
huh before look at this I bought the
$200 soja boy
console that's not expensive at
all it don't matter what the [__] you
like jco you stupid [__] you see what
I'm saying [__] it don't matter what you
like [__] it don't matter if
you okay you know it does to him if you
ain't like the song at first now you
like it now who gives a [__] who is
you who the [__] is you you ain't God I
mean definitely the greatest rapper
right now you
know you know what I'm saying you ain't
nobody you ain't bought my album you
ain't sign me you ain't put me on you
ain't put no money in no pocket [__]
buys albums now my pocket you ain't
doing future with me I don't know you we
ain't never met we ain't never collabed
you ain't never gave me no game so
resentful
dude let's hop in the studio and and
work [__] you what have you contributed
to my whole my life since I've been born
since to to this day what have you
contributed to my life and my career not
one [__]
thing what's he saying behind the be
verse a feature or a follow tweet [__]
I don't even know you I ain't never
spoke to you a damn my
life about
everything talk about you ain't used to
who gives a [__] what hey man explain
what happened you know worst recap
nobody never listen to jco I'm from
simple you like a Jay-Z ass nobody never
listen to Jay-Z nobody never listen to
you lyrical ass nobody give a
[__] this the high skill
level what did he say to him
Bo
boom what he said on a podcast or
something was that a podcast that he
said it
on oh wow and I was kind of living a
double life I had like a rapper life
like
where what the [__] is going on here
look dirty look dirty did one person on
Halloween dress up as jcole ah not the
litness
test not the test dude imagine going
into [__] Spirit Halloween where's
your J
coile that's a hilarious thing to
say who dressed up as soja
boy and how many dressed up his so boy
zero the end don't want to dress up as a
dirty ass bum Homeless looking the end
dude the
end how many people dress up as jov
Halloween how many people dress up as
Soulja Boy the
end dude what happened to Soulja Boy
game console sadly Soulja Boy Soul
Soulja games dude really running with
the soier [__] the misspelling of it you
know appears to be departing as quickly
as arise soja boys console and handheld
system are no longer on Soulja watch
website oh wow really running with it
the soldier scrutiny regarding this
Soldier legality of the young
entrepreneur um selling emulators which
came installed with other companies
games immediately arose this is uh from
Rolling Stone so it's probably a [__]
lie but
still um what is that oh yeah it was
called despite the success no that's a
different
thing damn video games are so I can't
believe how much I like the idea of
video games and I man I'm such a this is
how much I like the idea I never like
the idea of something more than this but
don't like the
thing I I'll see a commercial for a
video game I go oh [__] that looks
awesome I'll get up drop well I don't do
this anymore but because you can
download them all but I used to drive to
GameStop get the video game come home
and never play
it I'm telling you I've done it multiple
times I go oh that looks awesome be
right
back hi do you have [__] whatever it
is one please thank you very
much throw it on the couch I'm
hungry I'm GNA be jcole next
Halloween that's hilarious